I'm a heterosexual male you are a
heterosexual male correct right
so but that doesn't make us any more
manly than say a homosexual male yes it
does
Jesse can always be relied on for uh for
a real singer so I don't know I mean
what about
those ancient Greeks Achilles and
patrols you know the thing is though the
libs always try to say that all the
ancient Greeks were super duper gay and
that's probably overstated though you
know the difference between a Greek and
an Italian you know the Greeks and the
Romans were arguing over who had the
best civilization once that I invented
soufflaki they said I invented spaghetti
one says well I I invented uh sailboats
the other one says well I invented
Gladiator chariots and uh well says I
got you now the Greek says I Invented
Sex and you know what the Roman says the
Roman says sure but we introduced it to
women
[Music]